I love I love the like well I've watched
all your videos so we kind of get YC
it's like guys
these videos aren't YC like yes
[Music]
so this is Michael cybo with Dalton
Caldwell
and today we just finished up
um a YC batch and we're getting a ton of
feedback we thought it'd be great to
talk to you all about that let's be
critical for a second I would argue this
is something that YC does poorly that
they that they very clearly pointed out
they were like when we applied to YC we
really didn't know
what we were applying for one founder
said to me we just thought it was a
three-month program we had no idea that
you follow on investing companies later
that you have programs for helping me
raise a series a or for helping me as
I'm scaling we had no idea
um another founder said to me
we didn't even understand how YC was
organized we thought it was just going
to be some big online lecture like we
didn't know we would be assigned a group
partner we didn't know we'd be put into
groups and sections we get to meet with
small groups of companies that are like
in our area and like they didn't know
any of this stuff
and you know that's kind of a knock on
us I think sometimes we assume people
know but a lot of these Founders were
like well I applied to YC because I talk
to alums they really liked it and then
when I got here I was like oh [ __ ] like
this is way more stuff
than I am yeah uh you know one founder
was like dude we didn't even know that
you helped us hire and then
today there was a meeting about the like
YC hiring platform and we were like oh
we didn't know we we did
we spend seven seven percent we had no
idea what we're getting it for
I don't know why do you think we suck at
that though Dalton like it's pretty
obvious we're bad at it there's just a
lot of moving parts
and so people know about the batch
because they they hurt you know oh it's
a three-month program oh you moved to
the Bay Area and you spend time and even
then there's confusion it's like yeah I
know like you get to know us in person
sometimes we're like surprised that it's
really you and me that you meet they
think we're like paid actors or
something how many acceptables do you do
where they're like so am I gonna get to
work with like you yeah I'm calling you
the universe what's the front guys the
real the real so I know it's really us
and and so I think they know about the
program I think they may have heard
something about demo day but it's always
way more impressive than they expect and
then they have no idea that we keep
talking to the companies for a while and
there's all this other crazy stuff we do
to give people an edge
um a lot of which we kind of don't slash
can't talk about and so I think that's
part of the reason we don't Market it as
well is a bunch of the stuff we do is
meant to be secret
I don't know how you Market that
and there's just a lot of data that we
keep secret unless you're NYC and that
is like gonna stay that way
a lot of secret data you know the other
thing that's that that makes it hard
I've started to realize this it's too
easy to think of YC as a university
and
when I think back
you know I'm sure Yale has changed a
couple ways in the last 20 years since I
went but it's not changed that much
right I'm sure Stanford's changed some
ways since you went but it's not changed
that much and I think that when we think
about a university we're preconditioned
to think it's probably 99
the same year over year yeah and I think
what people don't think about why C is a
is as a product
right if you were to look at Instagram
day one and look at Instagram now it's
completely different and you would
expect that you would expect the product
to change all the time and I think
people's misconception is why I see as a
university or a school yeah it's not why
she's a product I think you nailed it we
talked to people about this I think they
think we have some lessons we're going
to teach you or something or like I love
I love the like well I've watched all
your videos so we kind of get YC it's
like guys these videos aren't YC like
yes anyway
so it's not like a school where we're
like here's our syllabus we're going to
read you here's our lecture here's
lecture four how to read these books
that ain't it it's more like
you're you're in the club and you get
access to the resources and if you are
ambitious and you are smart
the sky is the limit if you actually
work with people
that um
know what they're doing there's doors if
that opens and the bigger your ambition
is the more doors are gonna open you
know this is why it's a little dangerous
this is a dangerous thing I'll say you
know
we've been accused of being a mafia
and
we're not a mafia right we don't break
anyone's legs or anything like that
um
but it's not completely false right like
like
if you're like made in the mafia you do
get privileges that normal people don't
right and and like when you get to go
through YC you get access like you said
to resources that other people don't
right and so there and and
there's a little slightly different way
it's a little bit like the mafia
people don't [ __ ] on you as hard
you know like when you're in the mafia
like someone's not gonna rob you
right like when your YC VCS don't rip
you off like
and so I'm not saying it's a mafia right
I'm saying it's not enough we just have
these very clear similarities
to what I've seen on Mafia TV
oh God anyways so um
this kind of this part of the feedback
that we got from Founders it had it had
two elements one was we didn't really
understand the benefits that YC had when
we were applying
um it also had this
um aspect of there were some really
serious misconceptions that we had about
YC
that didn't get cleared up until we got
in you know one was this misconception
around like are we actually going to get
to work with you personally like is
there actual structure of this thing
where we feel like we're getting really
personalized support but but what are
some of the other misconceptions that
you saw that were you know
obviously I mean I would argue like
obviously designed to
try to convince people to not do I see
like these these were like designed
attacks on YC what else are you seeing
out there trying to trying to encourage
Founders to think that investors are
what makes your company great and that
you could get product ideas and product
Market fit based on who you let on your
cap table so you're like if I get this
investor they'll Judiciary and this
investor does this for me and so well YC
will do this for me
and it's like guys like the way you
build a company is not you're not baking
a cake where you where you sprinkle in
three different investors and then a
cake pops out like that's like the
stupidest thing I've ever heard this is
a really common misconception out there
which is like I hate to bring it to you
you're doing all the work all the work
we're not the reason the reason to do YC
is not that we're going to do the work
for you it's that it's a great
environment to do this with other peers
and Founders and get access to these
resources while you're the one baking
the cake and the amount of resources you
get in this network
way trumps the resources you get
from some random small check like yeah
similar size check right like
so I think that's one I think another
big uh misconception was
um
just folks a lot of folks that
apparently have the strongest opinions
of telling people about YC never
actually were in a batch
I don't know where that comes from so
just be just like be curious
because you know it's you don't like I I
just found her in my group this badge
and he was like well yeah everyone that
was NYC was like you should definitely
do YC and the people not NYC were like
oh it's not worth it and he's like in
retrospect
he's like now that I think about it
never you 'd product had opinions about
it and everyone who did use my product
had different opinions and I weighed
them equally yeah
you know the last one for me is this
crazy misconception about how far along
you have to be
it and and like what pains me about this
misconception is that it can be
destroyed through basic research
it's like look at the companies who've
done YC you've been successful and look
at how far along they were when they
applied yet over and over again
people will tell Founders like oh unless
you have this much revenue or unless
you're live unless you've been doing
something for this period of time or
like YC's for scaling but it's not for
starting it's like
garbage like literally 40 of the last
batch
came in with just an idea most of them
were working when they applied we're at
work working jobs when they applied it's
true and again let me just say the
brutal truth this is the brutal truth
some company
that their idea to start was to First
raise a pre-seed round and sell 30 to
some random investor have some
co-founder who lasted a year and then
they had to fire them and now they have
a bunch of equity who's gone through
three pivots and burned half a million
dollars and applies to YC Michael would
you rather fund that or the brand new
company that started a month ago they
just quit their jobs
the craft table is completely clean and
the and the founders were just like
totally jazzed and ready to start a
company like who do you think is more
likely to succeed uh yeah you know you
know
I think if you look at the last batch
it's very clear what our preferences lie
yeah people that their idea that you've
you know go to I go to YC once you're
ready to scale or once you've done all
the stuff and after that you know
exactly wrong dude how many companies we
funded the past few batches that
they have to change their idea which is
fine it's good to change writing we like
it
but they've already raised and they
already have all this hair on the
company and they think they're really
far along
how much harder is it to change your
idea once you have a bunch of
hair on the company because you thought
you were ready to scale so hard so hard
I I think that like
you know
it's so funny but in my mind it's so
clear
you do YC because you want an amazing
peer group
you do YC because you want to not be
screwed over by investors you do YC
because you want honest feedback
and you want to take responsibility for
the win
or loss of your company
and you do I see because so many other
great companies did YC and extracted
value out of it that you should be
confident that if you're a great founder
you can extract value out of it as well
it's that simple and and like
so many people that convince Founders
the YC's bad
they can't
explain why taking their money or doing
their program or doing their thing is
better all they can do is like
neg YC and like if you ever see someone
making an argument that's 100
ripping something else down and zero
percent explaining why their thing is
good if all of your talking points is
the alternative is bad
[Laughter]
uh you know
all you're selling is
is all you have to sell
and like maybe that's your business
model is selling fear
um not the kind of investor I'd want on
my cap table and then what's a reality
like inside of YC if you're a YC company
if
a batch
if you're getting the advice from us to
prepare for demo day
how'd it go Michael like like what did
we notice you know first evaluations I
think everyone was nervous that
valuations this summer would come way
down wasn't it like hashtag VC summer
vacation or some [ __ ] like that was
going on where no one was around
prices are almost exactly the same as
they were during the last batch when it
was like VC heaven on Earth and money
was flowing like like crazy we saw 15 to
25 some companies raised at 30.
almost no change from the last batch
didn't see any change on speed you know
we saw investors going from meeting to
Commitment within one to two meetings
didn't see any difference on terms like
you know investors weren't demanding
board seats or weird craziness
uh I don't know what do you see
all similar stuff and I think this is
like an evergreen lesson for everybody
why see alums or people not NYC is
it's too easy to take an anecdote that
you heard from people or stuff people
are saying in the group chat and think
it applies to you like one of the
classic mistakes we see from later stage
YC companies is they base how easy or
hard they think their fundrais will be
based on TechCrunch articles they read
of other people raising they're like hey
so-and-so just raised so I'm gonna be
able to raise the same valuation and
think about how much time you and I have
to talk people off the ledge on how like
some random company in Europe raising
for like some AI
whatever
doesn't magically mean their fundraising
to be easy right like you're it's like
bad data like garbage and garbage out
okay so again the advice for folks is
your mileage may vary I'm sure there are
people out there having a harder time
fundraise I apologize to you right I'm
not saying my experiences the
experiences YC companies have the same
as yours but this is sort of the meta
point I'm making which is too many folks
think fundraising is a market like the
stock market and if there's like graphs
in church you can have and it all
operates like an efficient market
instead of what it actually is which is
like 10 different things right Michael
like the YC funding ecosystem is like
its own little universe
own thing right it operates separately
than this other stuff a lot of what
people don't understand is the power of
running an auction
right like they just like it's so rare
that you really get to run an auction
you know most Founders early stage
Founders are not running an auction
they're begging for money like let's be
frank we Dalton you and I were there
right like we were we were begging for
money like
when you're in an auction
you get to do things like name your own
price
like why sea companies say to investors
were raising this much money at this
price are you in are you not in right
like that's that's that's a foreign
language to people who've like most
people have raised around oh we need to
lead to prices completely different for
YC companies I think the other thing
that happens
when you're running an auction that
people understand is
you get inbound offers
like a typical company in this batch got
between 10 and I've seen 60 or 70.
investors cold emailing them
wanting to learn about investing in
their company
I got Founders messaging me on slack
Michael what's going on and I'm like oh
yeah no this is just how this is what
nobody told you this is what happened at
YC they're like no and I'm like oh yeah
this is yeah investors cold email you
you don't cold email investors and
they're like
mind blown mind blown so I think that's
what's so funny is that
we talked to so many Founders who had
such a different experience fundraising
often from the same funds
before doing YC than after doing YC and
and let's dig into that like I think you
have like this great analogy around this
kind of early stage investing
environment like
try to kind of frame what's going on
here yeah my first company uh was in the
music industry for better or worse and
so I I learned a lot about in the eight
years I worked on it I learned a lot
about how the music industry works and
how Hollywood Works in general and I
started to see a lot of parallels
um between those Industries and Silicon
Valley again kind of depressingly if I'm
honest with you and it's the following
a lot of the folks
who are most approachable when you're a
first timer or when you're just moving
to the area or you're trying to break
into the industry the friendly people
that want to talk to you are often
the most exploitative and they're the
people whose business model is just just
like
squeeze you and like pull you up the
funnel to someone else and that and the
folks that you feel like they're doing
you a favor while doing yeah right
they're like they're Gatekeepers but
they're really friendly and you don't
know you're like oh you're a talent
scout oh you you like you know you like
the way my demo you came to my show like
whatever it is like there's folks who
really aggressively
um sell themselves to newcomers and part
of the pitch is oh I'm really important
I know all these important people I can
open doors for you
um you know here's some other people
that I know I can introduce you to them
like there's all these like kind of
promises
and sadly the story with a lot of folks
you know in the entertainment business
is um you learn the hard way that those
you you want to not talk to those people
or you want to understand
there's you want to make it to the to
the big leagues and get again if we're
talking about agents or something to the
extent you can get a really good
well-known agent that's like a large
agency like CAA or something all right
well then you made it like it's like a
key step to go from like
anyway we I don't want to get too deep
in the Hollywood stuff but there's
commonalities across these industries
and the thing I noticed in Silicon
Valley in my startup experience was a
lot of the characters that came out of
the woodwork and that they were most
successful to me is a first-time founder
in retrospect
we're not great no like hey give me
advisor shares to introduce you to
someone hey paid a pitch we have a pitch
competition come in hey you know like
all these angles
that weren't great and what's weird is a
lot of the people you know were like
medium famous and had like some social
media clout
like you like they did enough to seem
successful or drive fancy cars or seem
Rich that you would think they did
actually know people I mean you had this
too with like fake advisors right like
yes yes God I had a fake advisor who
literally took
two percent of our company
to
help us
fail at raising around that was rescued
by our existing inside investors
two percent
and exactly the same thing right like oh
really nice so I'm helping you out oh it
didn't work out but like you sign this
thing or what about my consideration I
shouldn't even sign anything
it didn't matter and so I think this is
like what's interesting is when talking
to YC Founders they have so many of
these horror stories of these kinds of
experiences fundraising before YC and
then they're shocked when like an
investor is like sure I'll sign a safe
don't need Pro rata rights I don't need
a board seed I don't need a board
Observer seat no I'm fine you know like
and the founders are like what do you
mean and it's like and
I think that it'd be helpful for us to
talk about some of those specific horror
stories that they tell us about right
um company in in my
um
uh group that raised money
um they were desperate
they raised a good chunk of money from
an investor
who um you know put in hundreds of
thousands of dollars and bought over a
third of the company straight away
and what they didn't tell that founder
is that every subsequent investor would
say to themselves huh this investor put
in a relatively small amount of capital
bought so much of the company that the
founders are going to get so diluted
they're not going to end up owning
anything and it's going to shut off
later stage rounds completely and you
know these founders of course that a
couple hundred thousand that wasn't
enough they raised more than raised more
they came in YC with almost 50 dilution
and it's like from an investor who knows
better but who saw that they could get
leverage over a founder and so they took
it this leverage point is fascinating
because so much of
when you talk to Founders that go out to
do a lot of fundraising
there's a lot of talking points that get
beat into your head
and it's easy to believe them uh like oh
I have to own 20 oh I have to have a
board seat oh if you raise it too high
of a valuation it's bad oh like and when
you think about it those are actually
very you know clever talking points from
the investor perspective and again so
many memes out there about fundraising
that are be are being pushed by folks
where it's convenient do you see how
it's actually
convenient to be like prices are down
and Founders should give up more rights
than they used to give during the
economy what are some other horror
stories man what else you got from this
badge yeah I mean I had
one where the investor the founder was
like Hey when we previously went out we
wanted to raise a million dollars and
the investor wanted us to do it as a
priced round
and to pay for fifty thousand dollars of
their legal fees
and I'm like
companies raise on safes
and pay nothing there are no lawyers
on this situation you hand 50k and and
the even more criminal thing is great
you want to do a price ground awesome
their standard paperwork for that it
shouldn't cost fifty thousand dollars to
a priced round like you're just ripping
off Founders pure and simple ripping off
Founders there are other situations
where someone is basically like oh I'm
committing to being your round but I
need to be the last money in tell me
when you've read yeah once you find
another million I'm in
but like you have to and you have to
leave room for me I'm like what
are you just making rules up this
doesn't this isn't how it works right
but Founders don't know we we got
another one where it'll be like someone
saying all right
um I'm committing 500 000 of your two
million dollar round you just have to go
and get the rest
I'm gonna lead you just have to go raise
that another 1.5 million like these four
these are like all horror stories over
and over from Founders in this batch
talking to us about fundraising before
doing YC and it's like
I I know why they were shell I know why
they were shocked when they did one
fundraising during YC they didn't hear
any of this [ __ ] and and what's tough to
say is
when you think about it to just go back
to the
to the music industry metaphor the
entertainment industry metaphor
for a lot of folks they were they would
have been better off or people would say
I was I would have been better off just
like waiting longer to get better a
better agent
or like be not having like a bad agent
just having no agent or so having a bad
manager who like stole the Masters for
me maybe having
and so this is what's weird is a lot of
the content marketing we get from The
Venture Capital industry is to convince
people they need it and want it
immediately
it's like the message that you're
brainwashed with is a is a Founder is
like you can't even start without
raising a pre-seat round and we're in
the business of pre-seed round blah blah
blah blah right and again like I hope
people never hear that from YC or they
don't get that from us we say the
opposite if you watch our other videos
we're like yeah like you don't actually
need to start with this money to like
start a company and to like get
customers like this is deeply part of
the YC Mantra which is if your idea for
how you start a startup is to First
create a pitch deck and go pitch VCS
you're setting yourself up to get
screwed
you're setting yourself up to get taken
advantage of who people uh by people who
are going to have 20 different ways to
rip you off versus
if you do something cool
um you're gonna have a lot more leverage
right
anyways
um
this was an amazing batch and I don't
want YC to take
too much credit here the founders at the
work like we said the founders at the
work and you know to one of the points
you made earlier being able to see
everyone in person this batch was also
just like amazing you know
it was
one of the things that reminded me about
why this is such a fun job is being able
to see everyone and interact with them
throughout the batch so this is a good
one right
this is good we made it yeah we made it
like we survived we survived at 19.
kind of nuts it's kind of nuts all right
man see you later
sounds good talk to you later
[Music]
laughs